A particularly important monadic operation
is referred to as thresholding.
Consider the two images here. The first one
is a grey scale image and the second image
you can see is much more contrasty; in fact,
the pixels have only got two values—they
are either black or white.
Now what we have done here is made a logical
decision on every input value. If the input
value is less than the threshold, referred
to by the symbol T, then the result is false
and we represent that by a black pixel in
the output image.
If the input pixel is greater than and equal
to T, then we say the result is true and the
resulting pixel is displayed as white.
If we display this function graphically, we
can see that it is very, very non-linear.
The output is 0 up until we reach the input
value of T, and then the output value becomes true.
In MATLAB when we display a pixel value that
has got a value of false, it shows as black,
and when we display a pixel that has a value
of true it is displayed as white.
MATLAB supports a number of what we call logical
operators. That is the way to compare two
numeric quantities. Just in the example before
we looked at the >= operator, and we also
looked at the < operator. MATLAB has the ability
to determine whether two values are equal;
or not equal; greater than; less than; and so on.
The result of any of these logical operators
is a logical value; it is either true or false.
Now MATLAB represents the concepts of true
and false as numeric values. True is represented
by 1 and false is represented by 0.
MATLAB also has some special constants that
are built in, and they have got the names true and false.
Let’s start with something really simple.
We will ask the question ‘is 2 greater than
1?’, and we know that the outcome of this
must be true.
And MATLAB has given us a value of 1. Now
we will note that we have created a new variable
in the workspace called ans. Ans is an automatic
variable that MATLAB uses to hold always the
result of the last operation or command that
has been given.
It is of logical type, which means it can
only have values of true or false.
So the answer that we got to this question
is 1, and 1 is the numerical value that MATLAB
uses to represent the concept of true.
Similarly, if we ask the question ‘is 1
greater than 2?’, and we know that this
is false, MATLAB has returned as a numerical
value of 0. It is how MATLAB represents the
concept of false.
MATLAB has got a couple of built in variables
to represent these values. We can ask it the
value of true. The equivalent numerical value
is 1. And false, the equivalent numerical
value is 0.
We can also do an equality test, so we can
say ‘is 1 equal to 2?’. It is not; it
is false.
‘Is 2 equal to 2?’ Yes that is true.
We can, of course, assign logical tests to
variables, so I can say ‘a is equal to 2
equals 3?’. We created a new logical variable
in that workspace called a, and it has a value
of 0, or false.
Earlier we looked at the concept of vectorization
when we perform arithmetic between a matrix
and a scalar. Well the logical operators can
also be used in a vectorized form. What happens
in this case is that the logical test is done
between every element in the input matrix,
and the scalar, and the result is a matrix
with the same size as the input matrix in
which every element is a logical value. The
elements in the output matrix are either true
or false.
Let’s show a concrete example of this. I
am going to create a matrix m and it is going
to contain random integer elements between
1 and 10. The matrix is going to be 4 by 4.
There we have it.
Now if I apply a logical test to this matrix,
what MATLAB is going to do is to compare every
element of the matrix with 5. It is going
to apply the >5 test to each element. And
so what we can see in this result: wherever
there are ones, this indicates an element
that is greater than 5.
You can also see that this result is a matrix
of logical type; that is, every element in
this matrix is a logical value which can only
be true or false, represented by the numeric
values 1 or 0 respectively.
I can apply an equality test to this matrix
as well, and I can look for all of the elements
that are equal
to 3. And what I find now is a matrix where
the two ones indicate the elements of the
original matrix that were equal to 3.
We are going to follow on from a previous
example and what we are going to do is create
a new variable; in this case it is going to
be called b. What I am going to do is to apply
a logical test to every pixel in the image
im, which is the image of the penguin sign
you can see above. And I am going to compare
all of these pixel values to the numeric value
0.45, and it is going to create a new variable
in my workspace and we can see that it is
of type logical.
We see it has the same dimensions as the original
image im. It has got 730 rows and 1047 columns.
It is of type logical. Each element in this
new matrix has got a value of either false
or true.
Now let’s display this logical image.
Here we go, and what we see now is an image
where the pixel values are quite crisp; they
are either black or white. The black values—I
click on here—have got a value of 0, they’re
false. That means that they don’t pass the
test—they are less than 0.45. Where a pixel
here has a value of 1, it does pass the test—it
is greater than 0.45.
Now, the question you might ask is where does
this number of 0.45 come from. Well I chose
it based on the histogram, because the histogram
indicates to me quite clearly that there is
a bunch of pixels with a value less then around
0.45, which are the dark ones corresponding
to the background. And then there is a set
of bright pixels generally bigger then 0.45,
which comprise the foreground or the objects
of interest, the icons and the characters
on that sign.
Now I can choose a different value for the
threshold. I can choose, for instance, I can
choose to make the threshold a little bigger.
I can maybe choose say 0.6, and I can display
that new image and we see now that the results
are somewhat similar. The small writing at
the top of that sign has disintegrated and
that often happens as you change the threshold,
some objects will start to fragment and disappear.
Rather than do this in a kind of clumsy trial
and error fashion, we can use the toolbox
function ithresh. We pass in the image that
we are interested in—im in this case—and
what we have is a slider. Up the top we see
an indicator of the current threshold value.
It defaults to 0.5. If I come down here and
grab the slider bar I can increase the threshold,
now it is 0.54. I can make it bigger, and
we can see that progressively as I raise the
threshold. Fewer and fewer pixels have a value
greater than the threshold and the result
is increasingly a black image.
Similarly, if I reduce the threshold down
here to say something like 0.41, we certainly
see that all the letters appear there quite
completely. As I reduce the threshold even
further what we will see is some bright parts
of the background starting to become true
when we apply the threshold test and eventually
the result is not quite so clear cut. So when
you choose a threshold there is generally
a sweet spot. Too low the result is all white,
too high and the result is all black. There
is a sweet spot in the middle.
Now choosing a threshold is a difficult thing;
requires a bit of skill, but primarily we
should be informed by the histogram which
tells us something about how the grey scale
values are distributed within an image. And
we use that to make an intelligent, first
choice of the threshold.